let's give bacteria all the love they
deserve we wouldn't be here without them
they were here for I don't know what it
is like a billion years before anything
else but in a way if you think about it
they create the matter that we consume
and then
and then we reincarnate or dissolved
into the soil and then creates an a tree
and then that tree creates more bacteria
and then that bacteria could I mean
again again that's why I like to think
about not recycling but reincarnating
because that assumes a kind of imparting
upon nature that dimension of agency and
and maybe awareness but yeah lots of
really interesting work happening with
bacteria
um directed evolution is one of them
we're looking we're looking at directed
Evolution so high throughput directed
evolution of
um of bacteria for the production of
products and again those products can be
a shoe um wearables biomaterials
therapeutical Therapeutics and doing
that direction computationally totally
computationally obviously in in the lab
with with with the hero organism the
hero bacteria
um and and and what's happening today in
in
um equal microbial synthetic biology
synthetic biology that lends itself to
ecology and again all of these fields
are coming together it's such a
wonderful time to be a designer I can
think of a better time to be a designer
in this world
um but with
um High throughput directed Evolution
and I should say that the physical space
in our new lab
um will have these capsules which which
we have designed
um that are
um that they are designed like growth
Chambers or grow rooms
um and in those Grow rooms we can
basically
um
program
um top-down environmental templating
right top-down environmental control of
Lights humidity light Etc so light
humidity and temperature
um while doing a bottom-up genetic
regulation so it is a wet lab but in
that wet lab you could do at the same
time you know genetic genetic modulation
regulation and and environmental
templating and then again the idea is
that in one of those capsules maybe we
grow transparent wood and in another
capsule we you know we transparent wood
for architectural application another
capsule we grow a shoe and in another
capsule we look at that language you
know large language model that we talked
about and there's a particular
technology associated with that which
we're hoping to reveal to the world in
February
um and in each of those capsules is
basically a high throughput
computational environment like a
breadboard that has think of sort of a
physical breadboard environment that has
access to oxygen and nitrogen and CO2
and nutritional dispensing and these
little capsules could be stressed
they're sort of a an ecology in a box
um and they could be stressed to produce
the food of the future or the products
of the future or the construction
materials of the future
um food food is a very interesting one
obviously because of food insecurity and
and and the issues that we have around
both in terms of
food insecurity but also in terms of the
future of food and what what will remain
after we can't eat plants and animals
anymore and all we can eat is these
false bananas and and and and and
um you know and insects as our protein
source so there we're thinking you know
can we design these capsules to stress
an environment and see how that
environment behaves think about a kind
of a an ecological a a biodiversity
chamber right a kind of a time capsule
that is designed as a
biodiversity chamber where you can
program the exact temperature of
humidity and light
um combination to emulate the
environment from the past so Ohio 1981
December 31st at 5 a.m in the morning
what do tomatoes taste like to all the
way in the future 200 years ago these
are the the input the environmental
inputs these are some genetic
regulations that I'm testing and what
might the food of the future or the
products of the future or the
construction materials of the future
um
feel like tests like behave like Etc and
so these capsules are designed as part
of a lab that's why it's been taking us
such a long time to get to this point
um because we started designing them in
2019 and they're currently literally as
I speak to you under construction how
well is it understood how to do this
dance of controlling these different
variables in order for various kinds of
growth to happen it's not it's never
been done before and these capsules have
never been designed before so I you know
first decided these are going to be
environmental capsules people thought
were crazy what are you building what
are you making so the answer is that we
don't know but we know that there has
never been a space like this where you
have basically a wet lab and a grow room
at that resolution
um that granularity uh of of of of of of
control over organisms
there's a reason why there is this
incredible evolution of products in the
software space
um the hardware space that's a more
limiting space that because of the
physical infrastructure that we have to
test and experiment with things so we
really wanted to push on
creating a wet lab that is novel in
every possible way what could you create
in it you could create the future you
could create a a you could create an
environment of plants talking to each
other with a robotic referee and the
robotic referee we you know and you
could you could
set an objective function and let's say
for for for for for the uh
um transaction driven individuals in the
world let's say the objective function
is carbon sequestration and
um and all of those plants are
um
are implemented with a gaming engine and
they have this reward system right and
they're constantly needing to optimize
the way in which they carbon sequest we
read out the bad guys we leave the good
guys and we end up with this like ideal
Ecology of carbon sequestering Heroes
that connect and communicate with each
other and once we have that model this
biodiversity chamber we send it out into
the field
um and we see what happens in nature and
that that's sort of what I'm talking
about
augmenting plants with that extra
dimension of
of bandwidth that they do not have and
they're they're just just last week
um I came across a paper
um that discusses uh the in Vivo neurons
that are that are augmented with a pong
game and uh and in a dish they basically
present sentience and the beginning of
awareness which is which is wonderful
like that that you could actually take
these neurons from a mouse brain and and
you have the electrical circuits and the
physiological circuits that enable uh
these cells to connect and communicate
and together arrive at Sort Of Swarm
situation that allows them to act as a
system that is not only perceived to be
sentient but is actually sentient
um Michael Levine calls this a gentle
material material that has agency right
so so so so this this this is of
interest to us because this is sort of
again this is emergence post templating
you template until you don't need to
template anymore because because the
system has its own rules right what we
don't want to happen with AGI we want to
happen with synthetic biology what we
don't want to have an online and
software with language we want for it to
happen with with bio-based materials
because that will get us closer to
growing things as opposed to assembly
and and mechanically yeah putting them
together with toxic materials and
compounds